well new information numbers out from
the bureau of labor statistics the
prices wholesalers pay rose 1 last month
and 9.7 over the past year and that is a
record near a record high it means
you'll be paying more consumers already
face inflation spiking in a four-decade
high and a supply crisis keeping many
store shelves empty yet house speaker
nancy pelosi appearing to downplay the
strain on your pocketbook watch
the fact that people have jobs
always contributes to increase in
inflation and that's a good thing but
inflation is not a good you know we have
to continue wages are not keeping up
with prices that's right when we passed
the competes act last friday this was a
giant step forward to address the supply
chain shortages that we have and
therefore will
decrease inflation
joining us now is fox news contributor
karl rove former white house deputy
chief of staff hello carl so is that
going to
work no it's not first of all
when we have low
unemployment meaning a lot of people are
working that may push up wages but it
doesn't necessarily push up the prices
of the goods and services we buy you
can't solve a problem unless you know
what causes the problem and the problem
of inflation is being caused largely
substantially by this
normally the federal government spends
roughly 20 percent of gdp
every year for 12 months however during
covet between late 2020 and 2021
the government was spending 40 percent
of the gdp
which means that it was putting out a
lot of money that it it that it it was
it was uh pumping into the system all
paid for by debt 5.8 trillion dollars in
covered relief was spent that's that's
that's a substantial chunk of money in a
relatively short period of time and what
happened inflation is too much money
chasing too few goods and we had put a
dollar 20 of income at a time when we
had 93 cents worth of goods that it was
chasing that's what was that's what's
caused inflation it's not that people
because people are working and getting a
good paycheck it's because prices are
rising because we're depreciating the
currency and pumping a lot of money easy
money into the system and as a result
too much money chasing too few goods i
don't know if the ar american rescue
plan came up with that interview tonight
i did not see it but that was what the
democrats passed last march of 1.9
trillion
but here's her quote carl the fact that
people have jobs always contributes to
an increase in inflation
now i mean
i took econ 101 but i mean beyond that i
really can't explain that because during
the trump years we had historically low
and unemployment numbers
and and stable and establishment we
talked about inflation
no price stability in during that period
of time look she got a failing grade in
economics 101 but you know she's in a
bad place she's she's responsible for
all the spending and remember she wanted
more she wanted the buildback better
plan which was 1.7 trillion dollars on
the surface of but when you took out the
gimmicks the committee for responsible
federal budget and the cbo both pointed
out that it was 5 trillion
the difference between 1.7 and 5
trillion was essentially paid for with
red ink which would have again
contributed to rising inflation and and
it this is a problem and we're going to
have the federal reserve and the
government the federal government itself
are going to have to do things in order
to to rein it in starting with let's cut
out the additional spending
carl do you think that this issue
in terms of what you laid out we can
follow it right but the democrats are
trying to find some sort of a shortcut
way to try to not have voters blame them
for their economic woes next november
art do you think the republicans are
sufficiently able at this point to be
coherent enough and work as a group to
drive the message that you were talking
about
well i'm not certain but i think they've
got an easier message to pull together
because people instinctively understand
where inflation comes from and that
comes from depreciating the currency
making the currency worth less democrats
have offered up several a couple of
ideas but president biden says well it's
the concentration of companies and he
pointed to the meat industry saying
there are very few big meat producing
companies you have a lot of people
producing meat at the farms and ranches
but the producers the processors who
make it into the kinds of things that we
see in the grocery store they're a
relatively small number of them but you
know what that the idea there is that
there has to be a conspiracy where there
is a limited number of producers for
everything because it's not just meat
that's up but milk is up and gasoline is
up and clothing is up and everything we
buy is up you know 17 percent increase
in housing costs there has to be a giant
conspiracy of a small number of home
builders that are driving up costs and a
small number of
apartment rental companies driving the
price up that that that's a nutty
conspiracy theory again you got to solve
a problem by understanding first what is
causing the problem and that is not
causing the problem thank you carl uh
good washington post piece today too
when you're appealing to emotions
and trying to explain them
you're losing what's all right go ahead
that's the surprise board it says
something about the super he even did it
in orange
sorry bill go bangles orange and black
nice colors carl hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now